la liste des participants à la main le
jury de la mairie de mort pas part à la
rencontre des 25 participants du premier
concours des décorations de noël
au total 19 maisons six appartements
jugée à partir de différents critères
on a par exemple les économies d'énergie
développement durable avec des lampes
qui donc économies d'énergie on a
également l'harmonie de l'ensemble des
couleurs des formes
on avait un retour des habitants où il y
avait un circuit un peu imaginé par les
habitants lors des périodes des fêtes
qui circulent et de maisons déjà très
jolie est vraiment bien décorée donc
face valoriser le travail et d habitant
maurepas c'était très important donc
voilà on a imaginé ce concours en les
mourres pas un habitué à décorer leurs
maisons sont au rendez vous des
guirlandes lumineuses dans les arbres
bonhomme de neige et animaux illuminé la
magie de noël enchante les quartiers de
la ville j'ai profité des végétaux qui
existait dans sur le terrain pour amener
daguenière
éclairer tout ça de différentes couleurs
parce que sanaa ce n'est pas un thème
il n'y a pas de thème c'est l'affairé
des couleurs les voisins sont assez fan
de ce que je fais me le font savoir donc
je suis assez fier de ce que je fais les
récompenses seront distribuées courant
janvier aux vainqueurs quatre prix
seront remis pour les maisons 2 aux
appartements
[Musique]